keep hearing the term Equity what would
in a world that has Equity look like
like would it be would it be 50 of
everyone in the same jobs would it be
like prison fifty percent fifty percent
so what does Equity look like so
equities generally described as a state
of fairness because historically a lot
of people have been arguing for equality
but what does that give us um like uh
like 0.5 of the one percent being woman
this doesn't really do anything for us
um and so people have talked about
Equity instead which is
um instead of sameness it's fairness and
this would mean that we remove systemic
barriers to
um to engage in society not just for
women but also for everyone so which
barriers